i'm chris wallace of fox news and i
welcome you to the first of the 2020
presidential debates
between president donald j trump and
former vice president joe biden
this debate is sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates
the commission has designed the format
six roughly
15 minute segments with two-minute
answers from
each candidate to the first question
then open discussion for the rest of
each segment
both campaigns have agreed to these
rules
for the record i decided the topics and
the questions in each topic
i can assure you none of the questions
has been shared with the commission
or the two candidates this debate is
being conducted under health and safety
protocols designed by the cleveland
clinic
which is serving as the health security
advisor to the commission for all four
debates
as a precaution both campaigns have
agreed the candidates
will not shake hands at the beginning of
tonight's debate
the audience here in the hall has
promised to remain silent
no cheers no boos or other interruptions
so we
and more importantly you can focus on
what the candidates have to say
no noise except right now as we welcome
the republican nominee president trump
and the democratic nominee vice
president biden
hello
gentlemen a lot of people have been
waiting for
this night so let's get going our first
subject is the supreme court
president trump you nominated amy coney
barrett over the weekend
to succeed the late ruth bader ginsburg
on the court you say the constitution is
clear about your obligation and the
senate's
to consider a nominee to the court vice
president biden you say that this is an
effort by the president and republicans
to jam through an appointment and what
you call
an abuse of power my first question to
both of you tonight why
are you right in the argument you make
and your opponent wrong
and where do you think a justice
barrett would take the court president
trump in this first segment you go first
two minutes thank you very much chris i
will tell you very simply we won the
election
elections have consequences we have the
senate
we have the white house and we have a
phenomenal
nominee respected by all top top
academic
good in every way good in every way in
fact
some of her biggest endorsers are very
liberal people
from notre dame and other places so i
think she's going to be fantastic we
have plenty of time
even if we did it after the election
itself i have a lot of time after the
election as you know
so i think that she will be outstanding
she's going to be
as good as anybody that has served on
that court we really feel that
we have a professor at notre dame highly
respected by all said she's the single
greatest
student he's ever had he's been a
professor for a long time at a great
school
and we just we won the election and
therefore we have the right
to choose her and very few people
knowingly
would say otherwise and by the way the
democrats they wouldn't even think about
not doing it if they had the only
difference is to try and do it faster
there's no way they would give it up
they had merit garland
but the problem is they didn't have the
election so they were stopped
and probably that would happen in
reverse also definitely it would happen
in reverse
so we won the election and we have the
right to do it chris
president trump thank you um same
question to you vice president
biden you have two minutes well first of
all
um thank you for doing this and looking
forward to this mr president
i uh the american people have a right
to have a say in who the supreme court
nominee is and that say occurs
when they vote for a united states
senators and when they vote for
the president united states they're not
going to get that chance now because
we're in the middle of an election
already
election has already started tens of
thousands of people have already voted
and so the thing that should happen is
we should wait
we should wait and see what the outcome
of this election is because that's the
only way the american people get to
express
their view is by who they elect as
president and who they elect as vice
president
now what's at stake here is the
president's made it clear
he wants to get rid of the affordable
care act he's been running on that
he ran on that and he's been governing
on that he's in the supreme court right
now
trying to get rid of the the affordable
care act
which uh will strip 20 million people
from having insurance health insurance
now
if they if it goes into court and
and uh the justice and i have nothing
i'm not opposed to the justices
she seems like a very fine person but
she's written before she went in the
bench which is her right
that she thinks that the affordable care
act is not constitutional
the other thing is on the court and if
it's struck down what happens
women's rights are fundamentally changed
once again
a woman could be helped pay more money
because she has a pre-existing condition
of pregnancy
we were able to they were able to charge
a woman more for the same exact
procedure amanda
gets and that ended when we in fact
passed the affordable care act
and there's a hundred million people
have pre-existing conditions
and they'll be taken away as well those
pre-existing conditions the insurance
companies are going to love this
and so it's just not appropriate to do
this before
this election if he wins the election
and the senate is
democrat a republican then he goes
forward if not we should wait until
february
there aren't a hundred million people
with pre-existing conditions
as far as the say is concerned the
people already had their say
they okay justice ginsburg said very
powerfully very strongly
at some point ten years ago or so
she said a president and the senate is
elected for a period of time but a
president is elected for four years
we're not elected for three years i'm
not elected for three years
so we have the senate we have a
president he's elected to the next
during that period of time
during that period of time we have an
opening
i'm not elected for three years i'm
elected for four years
and 100 million people jill the hundred
million people is totally wrong
i don't know where you got that number
the bigger problem that you have
is that you're going to extinguish 180
million people with their
private health care that they're very
simply not true well you said you're
going to socialism
he knows that what i proposed what i
proposed is that uh
we expand obamacare and we increase it
we do not
wipe any and one of the big debates we
had with 23
of my colleagues trying to win the
nomination that i won
were saying that biden wanted to allow
people to have private insurance still
they can they do they will under my
proposal not what you've said right and
it's not what that party is saying that
is simply the party doesn't say
your party wants to go socialist party
is and socialism right
now i am and they're gonna dominate you
joe you know that i am the democratic
party right now
the platform of the democratic party is
what i
in fact approved of what i approved of
now here's the deal the deal is that
it's going to wipe out
pre-existing conditions and by the way
the 20 the 200 million
the 200 000 people that have died on his
watch
they're how many of those and have
survived well there's seven million
people that contracted covet
what does it mean for them going forward
if you strike down
the affordable care act joe you've had
308
000 military people dying because you
couldn't provide them proper health care
in the military so don't tell me
about it happy to talk about that and if
you were here you wouldn't be 200
it would be 2 million people because you
were very late on the draw
you didn't want me to ban china which
was heavily infected
you didn't want me to ban all right
gentlemen which was heavily
unprecedented
you would have been much later mr prime
minister later mr president about two
million people you're not president
of the moderator we're going to talk
about covet in the next segment but
go ahead let me finish the point is that
the president also is opposed to roe v
wade
that's on the ballot as well and the
court in the court
and so that's also at stake right now
and so the election is all
you don't know it's on the ballot why is
it in the ballot what
because it's not on the ballot it's on
the ballot in the
court i think so in the court well
there's nothing happening there
donald would you you don't know her view
on
roe v wade i don't know well all right
let's
all right let's talk we got a lot to
unpack here gentlemen we got a lot of
time so
uh on health care and then we'll come
back to roe v
wade all right mr president the supreme
court will hear
a case a week after the election in
which the trump administration along
with 18 state attorneys general
are seeking to overturn that's right
obamacare to end obamacare you have
spent the last
because they want to give good help if i
may ask
questions sir good health care over uh
the last four years you have promised
to repeal and replace obamacare but you
have never in these four years
come up with a plan a comprehensive plan
to replace
obamacare of course i have well i'll get
rid of the individual
i'm going to give you excuse me i got
rid of the individual mandate which was
a big chunk
of that is absolutely a big thing that
was the worst part of obamacare
chris yeah that was the worst part of it
let me ask my question i'll ask joe
individual mandate was the most
unpopular aspect of
and i would like you to let me ask my
question and then you can answer
you in the course of these four years
have never come up with a comprehensive
plan
to replace obamacare and
just this last thursday you signed a
largely symbolic executive order to
protect people
with pre-existing conditions five days
before this debate
so my question sir is what is the trump
health care plan
well first of all i guess i'm debating
you not him but that's okay i'm not
surprised let me just tell you something
that
there's nothing symbolic i'm cutting
drug prices i'm going with favorite
nations which no president has the
courage to do because you're going
against big pharma
drug prices will be coming down 80 or 90
percent
you could have done it during your 47
year period in government but you didn't
do it
nobody's done it so we're cutting health
care what about all of the things that
we've done
yes i'll give you an example insulin
it's going to it was destroying families
destroying people the cost
i'm getting it for so cheap it's like
water you want to know the truth so
cheap
take a look at all of the drugs that
what we're doing prescription drug
prices
we're going to allow our governors now
to go to other countries to buy drugs
because
they pay just a tiny fraction this is an
open discussion
sir you'll be happy i'm about to pick up
on one of your points
to ask the vice president which is he
points out that you would like to add
a public option to obamacare and
the argument that he makes and other
republicans make
is that that is going to end private
insurance it is and well
if i start asking you the question uh it
will the party says by the way it will
end
private insurance and create a
government takeover of healthcare it
does not it's only for those people who
are so poor they
qualify for medicaid they can get that
free in most states except governors who
want to deny
people or poor medicaid anyone who
qualifies for medicare would
mean medicaid would automatically be
enrolled
in the public option the vast majority
of the american people would still
not be in that option number one so you
agree
with bernie sanders far left on the
manifesto we call it
man that gives you
the fact of the matter is i beat bernie
sanders not very much
i beat him a whole hell of a lot i'm
here i'm here standing facing you
would have left two days early you would
have lost every price knows how to
support tuesday you got to look very
long there's a deal i got very luck
gaming
very lucky tonight as well and tonight
i'm going to make sure
because here's the deal here's the deal
the fact
is that everything he's saying so far is
simply a lie i'm not here to call out
his lies everybody knows he's a liar but
you i just want him
to tell you that i i i i want to make
sure you did last in your class not
first
oh god i want to make a president can
you let him finish sir no he doesn't
know how to do that
he has you know christ you picked it be
surprised
the wrong guy the wrong night at the
wrong time listen you agreed with him
sanders said the mountains there is no
manifesto number please let him speak mr
number two
just lost the left number two i i you
just lost the left
you agreed with bernie sanders on a plan
absolutely do you have any idea
they call it socialized medicine
mr president tell you what he is not for
any help for people needing health care
because his because he in fact already
has cost 10 million people their health
care that they had from their employers
because of his recession number one
number two
there are 20 million people getting
health care through obamacare now
that he wants to take it away he won't
ever look in eye and say that's what he
wants to do
take it away oh i want to give numbers
better health care at a much lower price
because either way he doesn't know how
he doesn't know how to do it he fixed it
he has never offered to fix it to an
extent he has
never been as you might know but
probably doesn't
at the same obama and it's too expensive
let the president go ahead sir
obamacare is no good we made it better
and i had a choice to make very early on
we took away the individual mandate we
guarantee pre-existing conditions but
took away the individual mandate
listen this is the way it is and that
destroyed
that they shouldn't even call it
obamacare then i had a choice to make do
i let my people run it really well
or badly if i run it badly they'll
probably blame him but they'll blame me
but more importantly i want to help
people
okay i said you've got to run it so well
that's it and i just had a meeting with
them they said the problem is no matter
how well
you run obamacare it's a disaster it's
too expensive
premiums are too high but it doesn't
work
i have to give you roughly equal time
please let the vice president talk
he has no plan for health care yes we do
please he sends out wishful thinking he
has executive orders that have no power
he hasn't lowered drug costs for anybody
he's been promising a health care plan
since he got elected he has none like
almost everything else he talks about
he does not have a plan he doesn't have
a plan
and the fact is this man doesn't know
what he's talking about
all right i have one final question for
you sure uh mr vice president
if senate republicans we were talking
originally about the supreme court here
if senate republicans go ahead and
confirm
justice barrett there has been talk
about ending the filibuster or even
packing the court adding
to the nine justices there you call this
a distraction by the president but in
fact it wasn't brought up by the
president
it was brought up by some of your
democratic colleagues in i'm saying the
congress
so my question to you is you have
refused in the past to talk about it
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not you will
support
either ending the filibuster or packing
the court whatever position i take in
that that'll become the issue the issue
is the american people should speak
you should go out and vote you're in
voting now
vote and let your senators know how
strong you feel
let vote now make sure you in fact
let people know he doesn't we're a
senator i'm not going to answer the
question
because the question is the question is
justice
radical left would you listen who is on
your list joe
this is who's on your own right
gentlemen i think this is about this
we're not going to give a letter we have
ended this segment we're going to move
on to the second segment
that was really a productive segment
wasn't it
keep yapping man the people understand
yeah 47 years you've done nothing they
understand
all right the second subject is coveted
19 which is an awfully serious
subject so let's try to be serious about
it we have had
more than seven million cases of
coronavirus in the united states and
more than 200
000 people have died even after we
produce
a vaccine experts say that it could be
months or even years
before we come back to anything
approaching
normal my question for both of you is
based on what you have said
and done so far and what you have said
you would do
starting in 2021 why should the american
people
trust you more than your opponent
to deal with this public health crisis
going forward
in this case the question goes to you
first sir
two minutes uninterrupted good luck
two hundred thousand dead as you said
over seven million infected in the
united states
we in fact have five percent or four
percent of the world's population
20 percent of the deaths 40 000 people
a day are contracting covet in addition
to that
about between 750 and a thousand people
today are dying
when he was presented with that number
he said it is what it is
well it is what it is because you are
who you are
that's why it is the president has no
plan he hasn't laid out anything he knew
all the way back in february how serious
this crisis was
he knew it was a deadly disease what did
he do
he's on tape is acknowledging he knew it
he said he didn't tell us or give people
a warning of it because he didn't want
to panic the american people
you don't panic he panicked in addition
to that
what did he do he went in and he we were
insisting that the chinese
the people we had on the ground in china
should be able to go to wuhan
and determine for themselves how
dangerous this was
he did not even ask she to do that he
told us what a great job
she was doing he said we owe him a debt
of gratitude
for being so transparent with us and
what did he do then
he then did nothing he waited and waited
and waited he still doesn't have a plan
i laid out back in march exactly what we
should be doing
and i laid out again in july what we
should be doing
we should be providing all the
protective gear posts we should be
providing the money the house has passed
in order to be able to go out and get
people the help they need to keep their
businesses open
open schools that cost a lot of money
you should get out of your bunker and
get out of the sand trap and get in
in your golf course and go in the oval
office and bring together the democrats
republicans
and fund what needs to be done now to
save lives
so if we would have listened to you you
have two minutes sir
if we would have listened to you the
country would have been left wide open
millions of people would have died not
two hundred thousand and one person is
too much it's china's fault it should
have never happened
they stopped it from going in but it was
china's fault and by the way when you
talk about numbers you don't know how
many people died in china
you don't know how many people died in
russia you don't know how many people
died in india they don't exactly give
you a straight count just so you
understand
but if you look at what we've done i
closed it and you said he's xenophobic
he's a racist and he's xenophobic
because you didn't think i should have
closed our country wait a minute it says
two minutes you didn't think we should
have closed our country because you
thought it was too
it was terrible you wouldn't have closed
it for another two months
by my doing it early in fact dr fauci
said
president trump saved thousands of lives
many of you a democrat governor said
president trump did a phenomenal job we
worked with the governor oh really go
take a look
the governor said i did a phenomenal job
most of them said that
in fact people that would not be
necessarily on my side
said that president trump did a
phenomenal job
we did we got the gowns we got the masks
we made the ventilators you wouldn't
have made ventilators and now we're
weeks away from a vaccine
we're doing therapeutics already fewer
people are dying when they get sick
far fewer people are dying we've done a
great job
the only thing i haven't done a good job
and that's because of the fake news
no matter what you say to them they give
you a bad press on it's just fake news
they give you good press they give me
bad press because that's the way it is
unfortunately but let me just tell you
something i don't care i've gotten used
to it
but i'll tell you joe you could never
have done the job that we did you don't
have it in your blood you could have
never done that yet
i know how to do the job i know how to
get the job well you didn't do very well
in swine flu
h1n1 you were a disaster your own chiefs
14 000 people died not 200 000 there was
no
economic recession sure you made a
person
you made a point and there was no one
there's no we didn't shut down the
economy
this is his economy that's being he shut
down the reason it's shut down is
because
look you folks at home how many of you
get up this morning
and had an empty chair at the kitchen
table because someone died of covet
how many of you were in a situation
where you lost your mom or dad
and you couldn't even speak to them you
had a nurse holding a phone up
so you could in fact say goodbye you
would have lost father how many people
far more people than you would have been
and by the way
his own cdc director says we could lose
as many as another
200 000 people between now and the end
of the year and he held him he said
if we just wear a mask we can save half
those numbers
just just a mask and by the way in terms
of the
the whole notion of a vaccine we're for
a vaccine but we
i don't trust him at all nor do you i
know you don't well we trust as a
scientist
you don't trust doctors johnson
by the way let me let me move on to
questions about the future because you
both have touched on one of the
two of the questions i'm going to ask uh
focusing on the future first president
trump
you have repeatedly either contradicted
or been at
odds with some of your government's own
top scientists the week before last
the head of the centers for disease
control dr redfield said it would be
summer before the vaccine would become
generally available
to the public you said that he was
confused
and mistaken those were your two words
but
dr slawy the head of your operation worf
speed
has said exactly the same thing are they
both wrong well i've spoken to the
companies and we can have it a lot
sooner it's a very political thing
because people like this
would rather make it political than save
lives it is a very political thing
i've spoken to pfizer i've spoken to all
of the people that you have to speak to
we have great
modern johnson and johnson and others
they can go faster than that by a lot
become very political because the left
or i don't know if i call it
i don't know what the head of your
operation warp speed doctor i disagree
with him yeah no i disagree with both of
them
and he didn't say that he said it could
be there but it could also be much
i had him in my office two days he
talked about the summer sir before it's
generally available
she said it's a possibility that we'll
have the answer
before november first it could also be
generally available well we're going to
deliver it right away we have the
military all set up logistically
they're all set up we have our military
that delivers soldiers
and they can do two hundred thousand a
day they're going to be this is
the same man it's all set up by easter
this would be gone away
by the warm weather it'd be gone
miraculous like a miracle
and by the way maybe you could inject
some bleach in your arm and that would
take care of it
this is the same way you said sarcastic
that was you know that i
would've said sarcasm so here's the deal
this man is talking about a vaccine
every serious every serious company is
talking about
maybe having a vaccine done by the end
of the year but the distribution of that
vaccine
will not occur until sometime beginning
or the middle of next year to get it out
if we get the vaccine and pray god we
will
may god mr vice president i want to pick
up the vaccine
i want to pick up on this question
though you say the public
can trust the scientists but they can't
trust president trump in fact you said
that again tonight
your running mate senator harris goes
further saying the public health experts
quote
will be muzzled will be suppressed given
the fact that polls already show
that people are concerned about the
vaccine and are reluctant to take it
are you and your running mate senator
harris contributing to that fear
no more than the question you just asked
him you pointed out
he puts pressure and disagrees with his
own scientist
but you're saying you can't hear harris
is saying you can't trust the son
well no no you can't trust the scientist
he does she didn't say that you can't
she said the public health experts quote
will be muzzled
will be suppressed well that's what he's
going to try to do but
there's millions of scientists there's
thousands of scientists out there
like here at this great hospital that
don't work for him
their job doesn't depend on him that's
not
they're the people there and by the way
to the scientists that are in charge by
the way
they will have the vaccine very
seriously you believe
for a moment what he's telling you in
light of
all the lies he's told you about the
whole
issue relating to covet he still hasn't
even acknowledged
that he knew this was happening knew how
dangerous was going to be
back in february and he didn't even tell
you
he's on record as saying it he panicked
or he just looked at the stock market
one of the two because guess what a lot
of people died
and a lot more going to die unless he
gets a lot smarter a lot quicker
mr president did you use the word smart
uh so you said you went to delaware
state but you forgot the name of your
college
you didn't go to delaware state you
graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't ever use the word
smart with me
don't ever use that word oh give me your
because you know what there's nothing
smart about you joe 47 years you've done
this let's add this to ben
you would have had let me just tell you
something joe if you would have had
the charge of what i was put through i
had to close
the greatest economy in the history of
our country and by the way now it's
being built again
let's go get to the economy in the next
segment sir okay it's going up fast okay
when it comes to how the virus has been
handled so far
the two of you have taken very different
approaches and this is going to affect
how the virus is handled going forward
by
whichever of you ends up becoming the
next president i want to quickly go
through several of those reopenings
vice president biden you have been much
more reluctant than president trump
about reopening the economy and schools
why sir
because he doesn't have a plan if i were
running i know how what the plan
is you've got to provide these
businesses the ability to have the money
to be able to reopen with the ppe
as well as with the sanitation they need
you have to provide them
pelosi well he's just shush for a minute
tell it and humor by the way
nancy pelosi and schumer they have a
plan
he won't even meet with him the
republicans won't meet with the senate
but he he sits he sits on his golf
course and
i mean literally think about it you
probably play more than i do
what about this question of reopenings
and the fact that well he wants to shut
down this
country oh and i want to keep it open
and we did a great job
let me shut you down for a second joe
just for one second
we want to he wants to shut down the
country we just went through it
we had to because we didn't know
anything about the disease now we found
that elderly people with heart problems
and
diabetes and different problems are very
very vulnerable we learned a lot
young children aren't even younger
people aren't we've learned a lot
but he wants to shut it down more people
will be hurt
by continuing if you look at
pennsylvania if you look at certain
states
that have been shut down they have
democrat governors all one of the
reasons they're shut down is because
they want to keep it shut down until
after the election
you have begun to increasingly question
the effectiveness
of masks as a disease preventer and in
fact recently you have cited the
the issue of of waiters touching their
mass and touching plates
are you questioning that no i think
you have to understand if you look i
mean i have a mask right here i put
a mask on it you know when i think i
need it tonight as an example
everybody's had a test and you've had
social distancing and all of the things
that you have to but i wear masks when
needed
when needed i wear a mask okay let me
ask i don't have i don't wear mess like
him every time you see him he's got a
mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
i will say vice president biden go ahead
sir
look the way to open businesses is give
them the wherewithal to be able open
we provided money the congress i was
asking you sir about masks well
mask must make a big difference his own
head of the cdc said if we just more
mass
between now if everybody wore masks in
social distance between now and january
we'd probably save up to a hundred
thousand lives
it matters and they've also seen the
opposite they've also said no
no serious person said the opposite no
well look seriously
dr fauci said that he didn't ask very
strong
a minute left in this
subject because your different
approaches has even affected the way
that you have
campaigned president trump you're
holding large rallies
with crowds packed together thousands of
people i would say
outside yes sir agreed uh vice president
biden you are holding
much smaller uh events with nobody will
show up
people with what's true nobody shows up
to israel
all right in any case why you holding
the big rallies why
you not you goes first sir because
people
want to hear what i have to say i mean
what are you doing
and i'll have 25 35 000 people show up
at airports
we use airports we have a lot of people
well so far we have had no problem
whatsoever it's outside that's a big
difference according to the
experts and we do them outside we have
tremendous
crowds as you see i mean every and and
literally on 24 hours notice
and joe does the circles and has three
people someplace okay by the way did you
just did you one of the last big rallies
he has
and a reporter came up to him to ask him
a question he said no no no
stand back put on your mask put on a
mask
have you been tested i'm way i'm way far
away from those other people
that's what he said i can't i'm gonna be
okay he's not worried about you
he's not worried about the people out
there breathing in one of them we've had
no negativity
no negative effect we've had no negative
effect and we've had
35 40 thousand right people wanted
israelis just quickly finish up because
i want to move on to our next yes i
would he's been totally irresponsible
the way in which
he has handled the social distancing
and people wearing masks basically
encourage them not to
all right ben he's a fool if you could
get the crowds you would have done the
same thing but you can nobody can
gentlemen can we move on to the
appearance
can we move on to the economy yes the
economy
is i think it's fair to say recovering
faster than expected from the shutdown
in the second quarter the unemployment
rate fell to 8.4
last month the federal reserve says the
hit
to growth which is going to be there is
not going to be nearly as big as they
had
expected president trump you say we are
in a v-shaped
recovery vice president biden you say
it's more of
a k-shape what difference does that
mean to the american people in terms of
the economy president trump in this
segment you go first so we built the
greatest economy in history we closed it
down because of the china plague
when the plague came in we closed it
down which was very hard
psychologically to do he didn't think we
should close it down and he was wrong
and again two million people would be
dead now instead of
still 204 000 people is too much one
person is too much
should have never happened from china
but what happened is
we closed it down and now we're
reopening and we're doing record
business
we had 10.4 million people in a
four-month period that we've
put back into the workforce that's a
record the likes of which nobody's ever
seen before
and he wants to close down the he will
shut it down again he will destroy this
country
you know a lot of people between drugs
and alcohol and
depression when you start shutting it
down you take a look at what's happening
at some of your democrat-run states
where they have these
tough shutdowns and i'm telling you it's
because they don't want to open it one
of them came
out last week you saw that oh we're
going to open up on november 9th why
november 9th because it's after the
election
they think they're hurting us by keeping
them closed they're hurting people
people know what to do they can social
distance they can wash their hands they
can wear masks
they can do whatever they want but they
got to open these states up
when you look at north carolina when you
look and these governors are under siege
pennsylvania michigan and a couple of
others
you've got to open these states up it's
not fair you're talking about almost
it's like being in prison
and you look at what's going on with
divorce look at what's going on with
alcoholism and drugs it's a very very
sad thing
and he'll close down the whole country
this guy will close down the whole
country
and destroy our country our country is
coming back incredibly well
setting records as it does it we don't
need somebody to come in and say let's
shut it down
all right you're two minutes sir we're
now moved to you
as i as i said posing the question the
president says it's a v-shape recovery
you say it's a k-shaped
recovery what's the difference the
difference is
millionaires and billionaires like him
in the middle of cover crisis
have done very well another billionaires
of ray
have made another 300 billion dollars
because of his profligate tax
proposal and he only focused on the
market but you folks at home
you folks living in scranton and
claymont and all the small towns and
working-class towns in america
how old are you doing this guy paid well
total of seven hundred fifty dollars in
taxes
wait wait no sir it's just two yeah i
understand you've agreed to the two
minutes so please let him have it do i
get my time back
the fact is that he has in fact worked
on this in a way that he's going to be
the first president united states
to leave office having fewer jobs in his
administration
than when he became president fewer jobs
than when he became friends first one in
american history
secondly the people who have lost their
jobs
are those people who have been on the
front lines those people who have been
saving our lives those people who have
been out there
dying people who've been putting
themselves in the way to make sure
that we could all try to make it and the
idea that he is
insisting that we go forward and open
when you have almost half the states in
america with a significant increase
in covert deaths and covert cases in the
united states of america
and he wants to open it up more why does
he want to open it up why doesn't he
take care of the america you can't fix
the economy
until you fix the covet crisis and he
has no
intention of doing anything about making
it better for you
all at home in terms of your health and
your safety
schools why aren't schools open because
it costs a lot of money to open them
safely
you know they were going to give his
administration going to give the
teachers and school
students masks and then they decided no
couldn't do that because it's not a
national emergency
not a national emergency they've done
nothing to help
small businesses nothing they're closing
one in six is now gone
he ought to get on the job and take care
of the needs of the american people
so we can open safe all right your time
is up sir we are going to get to
i have to respond to that well you both
had two minutes sir
excuse me he made a statement so people
want their schools
no people want their schools open they
don't want to be shut down
they don't want their state shut down
they want their restaurants i look at
new york it's so
sad what's happening in new york it's
almost like a ghost town and i'm not
sure it can ever recover
what they've done in new york people
want their places open
they want to get back to their lives
people they'll be careful but they want
their school zone
i'm the one that brought back football
by the way i brought back big 10
football
it was me and i'm very happy to do it
and all right people of ohio are very
proud of me and
you're not going to get about that we're
going to get to your
economic plans going forward in a moment
but first mr president
as you well know there's a new report
that in 2016 the year you were elected
president in 2017
your first year as president that you
paid 750
a year in federal income tax each of
those years
i know that you pay a lot of other taxes
but i'm asking you the specific question
is it true that you paid 750 dollars in
federal
income taxes each of those two years i
paid
millions of dollars in taxes millions of
dollars
of income tax and let me just tell you
there was a story in one of the papers
i paid 38 million dollars one year
i paid 27 million show us your tax
returns
i went uh you'll see it as soon as it's
finished you'll see it you know if you
want to do
go to the board of elections there's a
118 page or so report
that says everything i have every bank i
have i'm totally
under leveraged because the assets are
extremely good
and we have a very we have a i built it
i'm asking you a specific question which
is
let me tell you i understand all of that
no mr president i'm asking you a
question
will you tell us how much you paid in
federal income taxes
in 2016 and 2017. millions of dollars
you paid millions of dollars of dollars
millions of dollars and you'll get to
see it
and you'll get to see it but let me
chris let me just tell you something
that
it was the tax laws i don't want to pay
tax before i came here
i was a private developer i was a
private business people
like every other private person unless
they're stupid
they go through the laws and that's what
it is he passed a tax bill
that gave us all these privileges for
depreciation
and for tax credits we build the
building and we get tax credits like the
hotel
on pennsylvania avenue you get a massive
which by the way was given to me
by the obama administration if you can
believe that
now the man got fired right after that
happened but vice president biden you
want to respond
yeah i do want to respond look the tax
code that
made him the put him in a position that
he pays less tax than a school teacher
makes on the money a schoolteacher makes
is because of
him take he says he's smart because he
can take advantage of the tax code
and he does take advantage of the tax
code that's why i'm going to eliminate
the trump tax cuts
and we're going to we're going to
eliminate those taxes and make sure that
we invest in the people who in fact need
the help
people out there need help but why
didn't you do it over 20 in the last 25
years
because you were president because you
weren't president screwing things up
you were a senator you're the worst
president america has ever had let me
let me just tell you joe i've done more
in in 47 months i've done more than
you've done in 47 years joe
we've done things that you never even
thought of okay including fixing the
broken military that you gave me
taking mr president we're talking about
the economy i'd like to ask you
about your plans going forward because
uh mr vice president your economic plan
if you were to be elected president uh
focuses a lot on big government big
taxes
big spending i want to focus first on
the taxes
you propose more than four trillion
dollars over a decade in new taxes
on individuals making more than four
hundred thousand dollars a year and on
corporations president trump says that
that kind of an
increase in taxes is going to hurt the
economy as it's just coming out of a
recession well just take a look at what
as
the the analysis has been on by wall
street firms
points out that my my economic plan
would create seven million more jobs in
his in four years
number one and number two it would
create
an additional one trillion dollars in
economic growth because it would be
about
buying american that we have to we're
going to make this federal government
spend
600 billion a year on everything from
ships
to steel to buildings and the like and
under my proposal
we're going to make sure that every
penny of that has to be made
by a company respectfully so i'm talking
about taxes not
spending well by the way i'm going to
eliminate a significant number of the
tax i'm going to make the
the the corporate tax 28 it shouldn't be
21
you have 19 companies 91 companies
federal i mean in the fortune 500 who
don't pay a single penny in tax making
billions of dollars why didn't you do it
billions of dollars
because obama because you in fact passed
that
that was your tax report i got it done
and you know what happened yeah you got
it down our economy boom
it's never boom the economy president
let me
mr president let me pick up on that you
would continue
your free market approach lower taxes
more
deregulation correct not lower taxes
american people
but in but in obama's you talk about the
economy booming
it turns out that in obama's final three
years as president
more jobs were created a million and a
half more jobs
than in the first three years of your
presidency they had the slowest
recovery since night economic recovery
since 1929
it was the slowest recovery also they
took over something that was down here
all you had to do was turn on the lights
and you pick up a lot but they had the
slowest economic recovery since 1929 let
me tell you about the stock market
when the stock market goes up that means
jobs it also means 401ks
if you got in if you ever became
president with your ideas you want to
terminate my tax
my taxes i i'll tell you what you'll
lose half of the companies that have
poured in here
will leave and plenty of companies that
are already here they'll leave for other
places
they will leave and you will have a
depression the likes of which
you've never seen look we inherited
the worst recession short of a
depression in american history
i was asked to bring it back we were
able to have an economic recovery that
created the jobs you're talking about
we handed him a booming economy he blew
it
it wasn't he he wasn't booming it was
it was the weakest request
is it fair to say he blew it when in
fact
when there was record on low
unemployment yeah before covet
yeah but because what he did even before
covent manufacturing went in the hole
manufacturing went not whole excuse me
number two number three they said you
would take no you were number two no
chris chris they said it would take a
miracle
to bring back manufacturing i brought
back seven hundred thousand jobs
they brought back nothing they gave up
on manufacturing
standard
i was asked to bring back chrysler and
general motors we brought them back
right here in the state of ohio in
michigan
he blew it they're gone he blew it and
in fact
they're gone ohio had the best year it's
ever had last year
michigan had the best year they've ever
had it's not any car companies came in
from germany from japan
went to michigan and went to ohio
they're not happening and they didn't
come everywhere
mr vice president and so you take a look
at what he's actually
done he's done very little his trade
deals are the same way
he talks about these great trade deals
you know he talks about the art of the
deal china has
made perfected the art of the steel we
have a higher deficit with china now
than we did before
we have the highest deficit trade
deficit china with mexico
china ate your lunch joe and no wonder
your son goes in and he
takes out he takes out billions of
dollars
takes out billions of dollars to manage
he makes millions of dollars
and also while we're at it why is it
just out of curiosity
the mayor of moscow's wife gave your son
three and a half million dollars
what did he do to deserve it what did he
do with baristas
totally discredited and by the way well
wait he can't get three and a half
million dollars joe
mr vice president you got three of the
president that is not true
really mr president mrs you it's a it's
an open discussion please
it's a fact well there's no who have
raised an issue let the
vice president answer discredited 183
thousands a month
with no experience and energy
my son did nothing wrong at first i
think he did mr president
he doesn't want to let me answer because
he knows i have the truth his position
has been
totally thoroughly discriminated by
everybody well by the media by our
allies by the world bank
by everyone has discredited matter of
fact
matter of fact people who testified
under oath
so let me ask you this i'm listening to
you
people under you've got three and a half
people testified
he testified under oath in his
administration said i did my job and i
did it very well
i did it i'd love to know who they are
every well i'll give you the list
of the people who tested it they've
you've already fired most of them
because they did a good job some people
don't know
here's it with you guys wait a minute
you get the final word
well it's hard to get any word in with
this clown excuse me this
hey let me just tell you no no i'm mr
president
that is simply why did he deserve three
and a half million from moscow look
here's the deal we want to talk about
families
and ethics i don't want to do that i
mean his family we could talk about all
night
his family's alright my family my family
lost a fortune
coming down and helping us with
government and that's such a right
mr president single one of them this is
not about
my family or his family it's about your
family
he doesn't that's not true it doesn't
want to talk about
what you need you the american people
it's about you that's what we're talking
about all right
that's the end of the segment we're
moving we're moving on it didn't take
them
vice president except can i be honest
it's a very important try to be honest
the answer to the question is no ukraine
no i sir
with a billion dollars you know what
you're waiting not
true you're doing it you're going to be
okay true gentlemen
i hate to raise my voice but i think it
seems to be why shouldn't i be different
than the two of you
so here's the date good point we have
six segments we have ended that segment
we're going to go to the next segment
in that segment you each are going to
have two uninterrupted moments
in those two interrupted minutes mr
president you can say anything you want
i'm going to ask a question about race
but if you want to answer about
something else go ahead
but we i think that the country would be
better served
if we allowed both people to speak with
fewer interruptions
i'm appealing to you sir to do that well
and him too well
frankly you've been doing more
interruptions that's all right but he
does plenty
well less than sir there's plenty no
less than you have
let's please continue on the issue of
race vice president biden you say that
president trump's response to the
violence in charlottesville three years
ago
when he talked about very fine people on
both sides
was what directly led you
to launch this run for president oh yes
sure president
trump you have often said that you
believe you have done
more for black americans than any
president with the possible
exception of abraham lincoln my question
for the two of you
is why should voters trust you rather
than your opponent
to deal with the race issues facing this
country over the next four years
vice president biden you go first it's
about
equity and equality it's about decency
it's about the constitution and we have
never
walked away from trying to quite require
equity for everyone equality for the
whole
of america but we've never accomplished
it but we've never
walked away from it like he has done it
is true the reason i got in the race is
from those people close your eyes
remember what those people look like
coming out of the fields carrying
torches
their veins bulging sputing and just
spewing
anti-semitic bile and accompanied by the
ku klux klan a young woman got killed
and they asked the president what he
thought he said they were very fine
people on both sides no president has
ever said anything like that
second point i'd make to you is that
when
floyd was killed when mr floyd was
killed there was a peaceful protest in
front of the white house
what did he do he came out of his bunker
had the military
to use tear gas on him so he could walk
across to a church and hold up a bible
and then what happened after that the
bishop of that very church said
that it was the disgrace the general who
was with him said
he only all he ever wants to do is
divide people not unite people at all
this is a president who has used
everything as a dog whistle
to try to generate racist hatred racist
division
this is a man who in fact you talk about
helping african americans
one in 1 000 african-americans has been
killed because of the cona the
coronavirus and if he doesn't do
something quickly by the end of the year
one in 500 will have been killed one in
500 african-americans
this man this man is the as a savior of
african-americans
this man cares at all this man's done
virtually nothing look the fact is that
you have to look at what he
talks about you have to look at what he
did and what he did has been disastrous
for the african-american community so
president trump you have two minutes
why should americans trust you over
your opponent to deal with racism crime
bill 1994
where you call them super predators
african-americans the super predators
and they've never forgotten it they've
never forgotten it jeff
no sir it's his two minutes so you did
that and they called you a super
predator and i'm letting people out of
jail now that
you have treated the african-american
population community you have treated
the black community
about as bad as anybody in this country
you did the 199
and that's why if you look at the polls
i'm doing better than any republican has
done in a
long time because they saw what you did
you call them
super predators and you've called them
worse than that because you look back at
your testimony over the years you've
called them a lot worse than that as far
as the church is concerned
and as far as the generals are concerned
we just got the support of 200
mil 250 military leaders and generals
total support law enforcement almost
every law enforcement
group in the united states i have
florida i have texas
i have ohio i have every
excuse me portland the sheriff just came
out today and he said i support
president trump i don't think you have
any law enforcement you can't even say
the word law enforcement because if you
say those words
you're going to lose all of your radical
left supporters and why
aren't you saying those words joe why
don't you say the words law enforcement
because
you know what if they called us in
portland we would put out that fire in a
half an hour but they won't do it
because they're run by radical left
democrats
if you look at chicago if you look at
any place you want to look seattle
they heard we were coming in the
following day and they put up their
hands and we got back seattle
minneapolis we got it back joe because
we believe in law and order but you
don't
the top 10 cities in just about the top
40 cities
are run by democrats and in many cases
radical left and they've got you wrapped
around their finger joe
to a point where you don't want to say
anything about law and order and i'll
tell you what
the people of this country want and
demand
law and order and you're afraid to even
say it all right
i want to return to the question of race
vice president biden
after the grand jury and the brianna
taylor case
decided not to charge any of the police
with homicide you said it raises the
question quote
whether justice could be equally applied
in america do you believe
that there is a separate but unequal
system of justice for
blacks in this country yes there is
there's just there's just
systemic injustice in this country in
education and work and in
in law enforcement in the and the way in
which it's enforced
but look the vast majority of police
officers are good decent honorable men
and women they risk their lives every
day to take care of us
but there are some bad apples and when
they occur when they find them they have
to be
sorted out they have to be held
accountable they have to be held
accountable
and what i'm going to do as president
united states is call a
a together an entire group of people at
the white house
blow everything from the civil rights
groups to the police officers the police
chiefs
and we're going to work this out we're
going to work this out so we change the
way in which we have more transparency
in when these things happen these cops
aren't happy to see what happened to
george floyd these cops aren't happy to
see what happened to
brianna taylor most don't like it but we
have to have a system
where people are held accountable when
and by the way violence and response is
never appropriate
never appropriate peaceful protest is
violence is never appropriate right
what is
i promise we're going to get to the
issue of law and order in a moment
this month your administration directed
federal agencies to end
racial sensitivity training that
addresses
white privilege or critical race theory
why did you decide to do that to end
racial sensitivity training
and do you believe that there is
systemic racism in this country sir
i ended it because it's racist i ended
it because a lot of people were
complaining that they were
asked to do things that were absolutely
insane
that it was a radical revolution that
was taking place
in our military in our schools
all over the place and you know it and
so does everybody else
racial sensitivity training if you were
a certain person
you had no status in life it was sort of
a reversal
and if you look at the people we were
paying people hundreds of thousands of
dollars
to teach very bad ideas and frankly very
sick ideas
and and really they were teaching people
to hate our country
and i'm not going to do that i'm not
going to allow that to happen
we have to go back to the core values of
this country
they were teaching people that our
country is a horrible place it's a
racist place
and they were teaching people to hate
our country and i'm not going to allow
that to happen vice president biden
nobody's doing that he's just he's the
racist
here's
the fact is that there is racial
insensitivity people have to be made
aware
of what other people feel like what
what insults them what is demeaning to
them
it's important to people know they don't
want to many people don't want to
hurt other people's feelings but it's
amazing it makes a big difference
it makes a gigantic difference in the
way a child is able to grow up and have
a self
a sense of self-esteem it's a little bit
like how
this guy and and his friends look down
on so many people
they look down their nose on people like
irish catholics like me and grow up in
scranton they look down on people who
don't have money they look down on
people
who are of a different faith they look
down on people
who are a different color in fact we're
all americans the only way we're going
to bring this country together
is bring everybody together there's
nothing we cannot do
if we do it together we can take this on
and we can defeat
racism mr president i mean president
trump sir during the obama
biden administration there was
tremendous division
there was hatred you look at ferguson
you look at
you go to very many places look at
oakland look what happened in oakland
look what happened in baltimore look
what happened
frankly it was more violent than what
i'm even seeing now but the reason
is that the democrats that run these
cities
don't want to talk like you about law
and order violence you still haven't
mentioned violence are you in favor of
law and order i'm in favor of law you
follow
are you in favor of the law you asked a
question
in order with justice where people get
treated fairly
and the fact of the matter is violent
crime went down 17
15 percent in our administration it's
gone up on his watch went down
much more all right mr president
mr president you're going to be very
happy because we're not going to talk
about law in order because we had
trouble with democratic-run
cities that's exactly my question there
has been a dramatic increase in
homicides in america
this summer particularly and you often
blame that on democratic
mayors and democratic governors but in
fact there have been equivalent
spikes in republican-led cities like
tulsa and fort worth
so the question is is this really a
party issue
i think it's a party issue you can bring
in a couple of examples but if you look
at chicago what's going on in chicago
where
53 people were shot and eight died shot
if you look at new york where it's going
up like nobody's
ever seen anything the numbers are going
up a hundred hundred and fifty two
hundred percent
uh crime it is crazy what's going on
and he doesn't want to say law and order
because he can't because he'll lose his
radical left supporters
and once he does that it's over with but
if he ever got to run this country
and they ran it the way he would want to
run it we would have
our suburbs would be gone by the way our
suburbs would be gone
and you would see problems like he would
have no suburb unless he took a wrong
turn
oh i know subbed he would have so much i
was like wait a minute i was raised in
the suburbs
this is not 1950. all these dog whistles
on racism don't work anymore
suburbs are by and large integrated
there's many people today driving their
kids to soccer practice and or to black
and white and hispanic
in the same car as there have been any
time in the past
what's what really is a threat to the
suburbs and their safety
is his failure to deal with covet
they're dying in the suburbs
his failure to deal with the environment
they're being flooded
they're being burned out because his
refusal to do anything
that's why the suburbs are interested i
do want to talk about this issue of law
and order though and
in the joint recommendation that came
from the
biden bernie sanders task force you
talked about
quote reimagining policing
first of all what does reimagining
policing mean and do you support
it means let me if i might finish the
question what does reimagining policing
mean
and do you support the black lives
matter
uh call for uh
for community control of policing look
what i support is the police having the
opportunity to deal with the problems
they face
and i'm not totally opposed to defunding
the police officers
as a matter of fact police local police
the only one defunding in his budget
calls for a 400 million dollar cut in
local law enforcement assistance
they need more assistance they need when
they show up for a 9 11 call to have
someone with them as a psychologist or
psychiatrist
to keep them from having to use force
and be able to talk people down
we have to have community policing like
we had before where the officers get to
know the people
in the communities that's when crime
went down
it didn't go up it went down and so we
have to be in that's not what they're
talking about chris
that's not where that is that he's
talking about defunding the police that
is not
true he doesn't have any law support
he has no law enforcement that's not
true that's not
look who do you have name one group that
supports you name one group that came
out and supported you
go ahead i think we have time we don't
have time to do that
all right one law enforcement group
that came back gentlemen i think i'm
gonna i'm gonna take back the moderators
and i want to get to another subject
which is the issue of protests
in many cities that have turned violent
in portland oregon especially we had a
more than a hundred straight days of
protests
which i think you would agree you talk
about peaceful protests many of those
turned into riots
mr vice president you say that
people who commit crimes should be held
accountable
the question i have though is as the
democratic nominee and earlier tonight
you said that you are the democratic
party right now
have you ever called the democratic
mayor of portland or the democratic
governor of oregon
and said hey you got to stop this bring
in the national guard
do whatever it takes but you'd stop the
days and months of violence
in portland i don't hold public office
now
i am a former vice president i've made
it clear
i've made it clear in my public
statements that the violence should be
prosecuted
it should be prosecuted and anyone who
commits it but you've never called for
the people
the leader excuse me sir you had never
called for the leaders
in portland and in oregon to
call us bring in the national guard and
knock off a hundred days of riots
they can in fact take care of it if he
just stay out of the way
look here oh really here oh really
here's another one
nobody get the killer of the young man
in the middle of the street they
shot him and for three days president
trump
go ahead sir and by the way you know his
own former spokesperson said
you know riots and chaos and violence
helpless cause
that's what this is all about i don't
know who said that i do
who i think kellyanne conway i don't
think she said
she said that and so here's that all
right but here's the point
the point is that that's what he is
keeps trying to rile everything up
he doesn't want to calm things down
instead of going in and talking to
people and saying
let's get everybody together figure out
how to deal with this
what's he do he just pours gasoline in
the fire
constantly and every single solitary
okay and and to
end this button up this segment i'm
going to give you a minute to answer sir
you have repeatedly criticized i have to
answer his stuff
you haven't stayed late no you've been
talking you made a statement
i'm asking you i would love to know sir
i would love to
you know if you want to switch seats we
could very quickly we could do that but
i'm saying
the national guard it would be over
there'd be no problem okay but they
don't want to accept the national guard
you have repeatedly criticized the the
vice president for not
specifically calling out antifa and
other left-wing
extremist groups but are you willing
tonight
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to do specifically
do it i would say almost everything i
see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you what are you
what are you saying i'm willing to do
anything i want to see peace
sir say it do it say it do you want to
call him
what do you want to call him give me
your name give me a white supremacist
and would you like me to conduct
this and write prophecy boys stand back
and stand by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about antifa and the left because this
is not a right-wing
problem this is a lefty director this is
a left-wing
white supremacist antifa is an idea not
an organization you got it
not militia that's what his tonight fbi
his fbi director said well you know what
no no no
we're done sir we're moving on to the
next one
everybody your administration tells you
the truth is it has a bad idea can i
tell you what you have no
idea and tifa is a danger all right
gentlemen we're now moving on to the
trump and black records and they'll
overthrow you when a president
i'm going to ask a question when the
president seeks a second term
it is generally a referendum on his
record but vice president biden you like
to quote one of your dad's
sayings which is don't compare me to the
almighty
compare me to the alternative and in
this case sir
you are the alternative looking
at both of your records i'm going to ask
each of you why should voters elect you
president
over your opponent in this segment
president trump you go first two minutes
because there has never been an
administration or president
who has done more than i've done in a
period of three and a half years and
that's despite
the impeachment hoax and you saw what
happened today with hillary clinton
where it was a whole big con job
but despite going through all of these
things where i had to fight
both flanks and behind me you know and
above there has never been an
administration
that's done what i've done the greatest
before covet came in the greatest
economy in history lowest employ
unemployment numbers
everything was good everything was going
and by the way
there was unity going to happen people
were calling me for the first time in
years they were calling
and they were saying it's time maybe and
then what happened we got hit but now
we're building it back up again
a rebuilding of the military including
space force and all of the other things
a a fixing of the the va
which was a mess under him 308 000
people died because they didn't have
proper health care he
was a mess and we now got a 91 approval
rating
at the va our vets we take care of our
vets but we've rebuilt our military
the job that we've done and i'll tell
you something some people say maybe the
most important
by the end of the first term i'll have
approximately
300 federal judges and court of appeals
judges 300
and hopefully three great supreme court
judges
justices that is a record
the likes of which very few people and
you know one of the reasons i'll have so
many judges
because president obama and him left me
128
judges to fill when you leave office you
don't leave
any judges that's like you just don't do
that they left 128
openings and if i were a member of his
party
because they have a little different
philosophy i'd say if you left
us 128 openings you can't be a good
president
you can't be a good vice president but i
want to thank you because it gives us
almost it'll probably be above that
number by the end of this term
300 judges it's a record looking at both
your records
why should voters elect you president as
opposed to president trump you have two
minutes uninterrupted
under this president we become weaker
sicker
poor more divided and more violent
when i was vice president we inherited a
recession
i was asked to fix it i did we left him
a booming economy
and he caused the recession with regard
to
being weaker the fact is that i've gone
head-to-head with putin
and made it clear to him we're not going
to take any of his stuff he's putin's
puppy he still refuses to even
say anything to putin about the bounty
on the heads of american soldiers
no no no million dollars and by the way
mr price
wait a minute mr president your campaign
agreed
to both sides would get two-minute
answers
uninterrupted well your your side agreed
to it and
why don't you observe what your campaign
agreed to as a ground rule okay sir
he never keeps his word no no i'm not
absolutely
that was a rhetorical question can you
go ahead back 30 seconds
yeah yes you may have all right go ahead
so
thirdly we're poor the billionaires have
gotten much
much more wealthy by a tune of over
three to four hundred billion dollars
more
just since covent you in the home you
got
less you're in more trouble than you
were before
in terms of being more violent when we
were in office there were 15 percent
less violence in america than there is
today he's president united states
it's on his watch and with regard to
more divided
the nation can't stay divided we can't
be this way
and speaking of my son the way you talk
about the military
the way you talk about them being losers
and being
and and and just being suckers my son
was in iraq he spent a year there
he got he got the bronze star he got the
conspicuous service medal
he was not a loser he was a patriot
and the people left behind there were
heroes really and i resent you talking
about
hunter are you talking about i'm talking
about my son beau biden you're talking i
don't know
i don't know beau i know hunter hunter
got thrown hunter got thrown out of the
military
he was thrown out dishonorably
discharged that's not true
cocaine use and he didn't have a job
until you became vice president
what do you mean he made a fortune in
ukraine
in china in moscow that is simply
various other places
my son fortunately generally my son and
he didn't have a giant my son
like a lot of people like a lot of
people we know at home
had a drug problem he's overtaken it
he's
he's he's fixed it he's worked on it and
i'm proud of him but why was he out of
here
but he wasn't giving 10 million that is
totally
president totally you've already been
we've already been through this i think
the american people would rather hear
about more substantial
subjects well you know as the moderator
sir i'm going to make a judgment call
here
three and a half million dollars from
the money about moscow
mitt romney on that committee said it
wasn't worth taxpayers money that
reporter was written for political
reasons you know
i'd like to talk about climate change so
would i okay
the forest fires in the west are raging
now they have burned
millions of acres they have displaced
hundreds of thousands of people when
state officials there blame the fires on
climate change mr president you said i
don't think the science
knows over your four years you have
pulled the u.s
out of the paris climate accord you have
rolled back a number of
obama environmental records what
do you believe about the science of
climate change
and what will you do in the next four
years to confront it
i want crystal clean water and air i
want beautiful clean air we have now the
lowest carbon
if you look at our numbers right now we
are
doing phenomenally but i haven't
destroyed our businesses
our businesses aren't put out of
commission if you look at
the paris accord it was a disaster from
our standpoint
and people are actually very happy about
what's going on
because our businesses are doing well as
far as the fires are concerned
you need forest management in addition
to everything else
the forest floors are loaded up with
trees dead trees that are years old and
they're like tinder
and leaves and everything else you drop
a cigarette in there the whole forest
burns down
you've got to have forest management
what do you believe what do you believe
about the science of climate change sir
i believe that we have to do everything
we can to have
immaculate air immaculate water and do
whatever else we can that's good you
know we're planting a billion trees the
billion tree project
and it's very exciting you believe that
human
pollution gas greenhouse gas emissions
contributes to the global warming
i think a lot of things do but i think
to an extent yes i think to an extent
yes but i also think
we have to do better management of our
forests every
year i get the call california's burning
california's burning if that was cleaned
if that were if you had forest
management good
forest management you wouldn't be
getting those calls you know in europe
they live their forest cities they call
forest cities
they maintain their forest they manage
their forests
i was with the head of a major country
it's a forest city
he said sir we have trees that are far
more they they ignite
much easier than california there
shouldn't be that problem i spoke with
the governor about it i'm getting along
very well with the governor
but i said you know at some point you
can't every year have
hundreds of thousands of acres of land
just burned to the ground
that's burning down because of a lack of
sir if you believe
in the science of climate change why
have you rolled back the obama
clean power plan which limited carbon
emissions in power plants why have you
relaxed because it was driving energy
prices through the sky why have you
relaxed fuel economy
standards that are going to create more
pollution from cars well not really
because what's happening is the car is
much less expensive and it's a much
safer car
and you're talking about a tiny
difference and then what would happen
because of the cost of the car
you would have at least double and
triple the number of cars purchased we
have the old slugs out there that are 10
12 years old
if you did that the car would be safer
it would be much cheaper but
30 500 they've simply take a lot of cars
off the market because people would be
able to afford a car
now so and by the way we're going to see
how that turns out but a lot of people
agree with me many people
the car has gotten so expensive because
they have computers all over the place
for an extra little bit okay of gasoline
and
and i'm okay with electric cars too i
think i'm all for electric cars i've
given big incentives for electric cars
but what they've done in california is
just crazy
vice president biden i'd like you to to
respond to the president's climate
change record but i also want to ask you
about a concern you propose
2 trillion dollars in green jobs you
talk about
new limits not abolishing but new limits
on fracking
ending the use of fossil fuels to
generate electricity by 2035
and zero net emission of greenhouse
gases by 2050
the president says a lot of these things
would
tank the economy and cost millions of
jobs he's absolutely wrong
number one number two if in fact when
our during our administration the
recovery act i was able to i was in
charge able to bring down the cost
of renewable energy to cheaper than or
as cheap as
coal and gas and oil nobody's going to
build
another coal-fired plant in america
no one's going to build another
oil-fired plant in america they're going
to move to renewable energy number one
number two we're going to make sure that
we are able to take
the federal fleet and turn it into a
fleet that's
run on their electric vehicles making
sure that we can do that we're going to
put 500
000 charging stations and all of the
highways that we're going to be building
in the future
we're going to build a economy that in
fact is going
to provide for the ability us to take
four million buildings
and make sure that they in fact are
weatherized in a way that in fact will
they'll emit significantly less gas and
oil because the heat will not be going
out
there's so many things that we can do
now to create
thousands and thousands of jobs we can
get to net
zero in terms of energy production
by 2035 not only not costing people jobs
creating jobs
creating millions of good paying jobs
not
15 bucks an hour but prevailing wage
by having a new infrastructure that in
fact is green
and the first thing i will do i will
rejoin the paris accord
i will join the paris accord because
with us out of it look what's happening
it's all falling apart and talk about
someone who has no
no relationship to with foreign policy
brazil the rainforest of brazil
are being torn down are being ripped
down more
more carbon is absorbed in that
rainforest than every bit of carbon
that's admitted in the united states
instead of doing something about that i
would be gathering up and making sure we
had to come
the countries of the world coming up
with 20 billion dollars say here's 20
billion dollars
stop stop tearing down
the forest and if you don't then you're
going to have significant
economic consequences what about the
argument that president trump basically
says
that you have to balance environmental
interests
and economic interests and he's drawn
his line
well he hadn't drawn a line he still for
example make sure that we he wants to
make sure that
methane is not a problem we can you you
can now emit more methane without it
being a problem
methane this is a guy who says that you
don't have to have mileage standards for
automobiles that exist now
this is a guy who says that the fact did
it's it's all true and here's thinking
about the green new deal and it's not 2
billion
or 20 billion as you said it's 100
trillion dollars i'm talking about
they want to rip down buildings and
rebuild the building it's the
most redundant where airplanes are out
of business
where two car systems are out where they
want to take out the cows too
you know that's not true either right
this is a this is a 100 trillion
that's more money than our country could
make in a hundred years if we're not
the case all right let me let me let me
just because i actually wait a minute
sir i actually have studied your plan
and it includes upgrading four million
buildings weatherizing two million
hounds over four years building one and
a half million energy efficient
homes so the question becomes some
the president is saying i think some
people who support the president would
say
that sounds like it's going to cost a
lot of money and hurt the economy what
it's going to do it's going to create
thousands and millions of jobs good
paying jobs let him finish sir
he doesn't know how to do that 100
billion the fact is it's going to create
millions of good paying jobs and these
tax
incentives to people for people to
weatherize which he wants to get
get rid of it's going to make the
economy much safer look how much we're
paying now
to deal with the hurricanes with the
deal with by the way he has an answer
for hurricanes he said
maybe we should drop a nuclear weapon on
them they may i never said that
actually he did made it up uh and here's
the deal
you make up we are going to be in a
position where
we can create hard hard good
jobs by making sure the environment is
clean
and we all are in better shape we spend
billions of dollars now
billions of dollars on floods hurricanes
rising seas
we're in real trouble look what's
happening just in the midwest with these
storms that come through and wipe out
entire sections and counties
in iowa they didn't happen before
they're because of global
warming we make up 15 percent of the
world's
problem we in fact but the rest of the
world we've got to get him to come along
that's what we have to get back
into back into the paris accord all
right gentlemen wait a minute chris so
why didn't he do it for 47 years you
were vice president why didn't you get
the world
china sends up real dirt into the air
russia does
india does they all do we're supposed to
be good and by the way
he made a couple of statements the green
new deal is a hundred trillion dollars
that is not
my plan that's green well we want to
rebuild everything my plan is
he said i said something about the
military he and his friends made it up
and then they went with it i never said
it okay that is
the final question is i can't remember
which of all is ranties
i'm having a little trouble myself but
uh and about the economy and about this
question of what it's going to cost
the the economy i mean the green new
deal and the idea of what what your
environmental changes will do
the green new deal will pay for itself
as we move forward
we're not going to build plants that in
fact are
great polluting plants you're going to
build a brand new deal pardon me do you
support no i don't support the green
don't oh well that's a big statement i
support you just
the radical left i suspect i support the
biden plan
that i put forward okay the biden plan
which is different than
what he calls the radical green new deal
all right gentlemen
final segment election integrity as we
meet
tonight millions of americans are
receiving
mail-in ballots or going to vote early
how confident should we be that this
will be a fair election and what are you
prepared to do
over the next five plus weeks because
it'll not only be to election day but
also
counting some ballots mail-in ballots
after election day
what are you prepared to do to reassure
the american people that the next
president
will be the legitimate winner of this
election
in this final segment mr vice president
you go first prepare to let people vote
they should go to iwillvote.com
decide how they're going to vote when
they're going to vote and what means by
which they're going to vote
his own homeland security director as
well as the fbi director says there is
no evidence at all that mail and ballots
are a source of of being manipulated and
cheating
they said that the fact is that there
are going to be millions of people
because of covet
that are going to be voting by mail and
ballots like he does by the way
he sits behind the resolute desk and
sends his ballot to florida
number one number two we're going to
make sure that those people who
want to vote in person are able to vote
because enough poll watchers are there
to
make sure they can socially distance the
polls are open on time
and their polls stay open until the
votes are counted and this is all about
trying
to dissuade people from voting because
he's trying to con
to scare people into thinking that it's
not going to be legitimate
show up and vote you will determine the
outcome of this election
vote vote vote if you're able to vote
early in your state vote early
if you're able to vote in person vote in
person vote whatever way is the best way
for you
because you will he cannot stop you from
being able to determine the outcome of
this election
and in terms of whether or not when the
votes are counted and they're all
counted
that will be accepted if i win that will
be accepted if i lose that'll be
accepted but by the way
if in fact he says he's not sure what
he's going to accept
well let me tell you something it
doesn't matter because if we get the
votes
it's going to be all over he's going to
go he can't stay in power
it won't happen it won't happen so vote
just make sure you understand you have
it
in your control to determine what this
country's going to look like the next
four years
is it going to change you get four more
years of these lies
mr president two minutes so when i
listened to joe talking about a
transition there's been no transition
from when i won i won that election
and if you look at crooked hillary
clinton if you look at all of the
different people
there was no transition because they
came after me trying to do a coup
they came after me spying on my campaign
they started from the day i won and even
before i won from the day i came down
the escalator with our first lady
they were a disaster they were disgraced
to our country
and we've caught them we've caught them
all we've got it all on tape we've
caught them all and by the way you gave
the idea for the logan act against
general flynn
you better take a look at that because
we caught you in a sense and
president obama was sitting in the
office he knew about it too so don't
tell me about a free transition
as far as the ballots are concerned it's
a disaster
a solicited ballot okay
solicit it is okay you're soliciting
you're asking they send it back you send
it back
i did that if you have an unsolicited
they're sending millions of ballots all
over
the country there's fraud they found him
in creeks
they found some with the name trump just
happened to have the name trump
just the other day in a waste paper
basket they're being sent all over the
place
they sent two in a democrat area they
sent out a thousand ballots everybody
got two ballots
this is going to be a fraud like you've
never seen the other thing
it's nice on november 3rd you're
watching and you see who won the
election
and i think we're going to do well
because people are really happy with the
job we've done but you know what
we won't know we might not know for
months because these ballots are going
to be all over
take a look at what happened in
manhattan take a look at what happened
in
new jersey take a look at what happened
in virginia and other places
they're not losing two percent one
percent which by the way is too much an
election could be won or lost with that
they'll listen 30 and 40 it's a fraud
and it's a shame and can you imagine
where they say
uh you have to have your ballot in by
november 10th
november 10th that means that's seven
days
after the election in theory should have
been announced okay
we have made your states with that sorry
all run by david
says two minutes all run by democrats
president trump it's a regular
you're going to be able to continue you
have been charging for months and
mail-in balloting is going to be a
disaster
you say it's rigged that it's going to
lead to fraud
but in 2018 in the last midterm election
31 million
people voted mail-in voting that was
a quarter more than a quarter of all the
voters that year cast their ballots by
mail
now that millions of mail-in ballots
have gone out
what are you going to do about it and
are you counting on the supreme court
including a justice barrett to settle
any dispute yeah i think i'm counting on
them to look at the ballots definitely i
don't think well i hope we don't need
them
in terms of the election itself but for
the ballots i think so
because what's happening is incredible i
just heard i read today where at least
one percent of the ballots for 2016
were invalidated they they take them we
don't like them we don't like them there
are millions of ballots going on what
you do is you go and vote
you do a solicited ballot no no that's
okay i know where you going
i'm asking you about the fact that
millions of people you go and vote
you go and vote but like they think they
used
millions you either do chris a solicited
ballot where you're sending it in
they're sending it back and you're
sending
they have mailman with lots of it did
you see what's going on take a look at
west virginia mailman selling the
ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers this is a horrible thing for
our country there is no this is not
there is no
this is not going to end well okay this
is not going vice president obama five
states i've had
mailing ballots for the last decade or
more five
including two republican states and you
don't have to solicit the ballot it's
sent to you
it's sent to your home what we're saying
is they're saying is that it has to be a
postmark
by the time by election day if it
doesn't get in until the
seventh eighth ninth it still should be
counted
he's just afraid of counting the votes
because you're wrong
i want to continue with you on this vice
president biden because he's so wrong
when he makes it
happen excuse me vice president biden
the biggest problem in fact over the
years with mail-in voting
has not been fraud historically it has
been
that sizable number sometimes hundreds
of thousands of ballots are thrown out
because they have not been properly
filled out or there is some other
irregularity or they must be
the deadline so the question i have is
are you concerned
that the supreme court with a justice
barrett will settle any dispute
i am concerned that any court would
settle this because here's the deal
when you when you file when you get a
ballot
and you fill it out you're supposed to
have an affidavit if you didn't know you
have
someone say that this is me you should
be able to
if in fact you can verify that you when
the before the ballot is thrown out
that's sufficient to be able to count
the ballot because someone made a
mistake
and not dotting the correct die who they
voted for
testify say who they voted for
say it's you that is totally legitimate
all right excited
i have a financial senator it's swamping
my system you you know it can't be done
you know it can't and already all right
election workers are prohibited
currently by law eight states
from even beginning to process ballots
even take them out of the envelopes and
flatten them until election day that
means that it's likely because there's
going to be a huge increase
in mail-in balloting that we are not
going to know
on election night who the winner is that
it could be days
it could be weeks until we find out who
the
the new president is so i first for you
sir
finally for the for the vice president i
hope neither of you will interrupt the
other
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in any
civil unrest and will you pledge tonight
that you will not declare victory
until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you for joining my
supporters to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen
i am urging them to do it as you know
today there was a big problem
in philadelphia they went in to watch
they were called poll watchers a very
safe very nice thing
they were thrown out they weren't
allowed to watch you know why
because bad things happen in
philadelphia bad things
and i am urging i am marriaging my
people i hope it's going to be a fair
election if it's a fair election
what i am a hundred percent on board but
if i see
tens of thousands of ballots being
manipulated i can't go along with that
and i'll tell you what is that from a
common sense does that mean you're
telling other people to take time it
means you have a fraudulent election
you're sending out 80 million ballots
they're not equipped
these people aren't equipped to handle
it number one number two
they cheat they cheat hey they found
ballots in a waste paper basket three
days ago
and they all had the name military
ballots they were military they all had
the name
trump on them vice versa i think that's
good vice president biden final question
for you will
you urge your supporters to stay calm
while the vote is counted and will you
pledge
not to declare victory until the
election is independently certified
yes and here's the deal we count the
ballots as you pointed out
some of these ballots in some states
can't even be opened until
election day and if there's thousands of
ballots going to take time to do it and
by the way
our military they've been voting by
ballots
first since at the end of the civil war
in effect and that's
and that's what's happened going to
happen why was it not why is it for them
somehow not fraudulent it's the same
process
it's honest no one has established at
all
that there is fraud related to male
imbalance that somehow it's a fraudulent
process it's already been established
take a look at caroline maloney's race
you had an opportunity to look at
caroline
they have no idea why is president go
ahead he has no idea what he's talking
about here's the deal
the fact is i will accept it and he will
too you know why
because once the winner is declared
after all the
all the ballots are counted all the
votes are counted that'll be the end of
it
that'll be the end of it and if it's me
in fact fine if
it's not me i'll support the outcome and
i'll be a president not just for the
democrats i'll be a president for
democrats and republicans
and this guy i want to say honestly
gentlemen
would you say that's the end of this
this is the end of this debate this
ballot count
we're going to to be continued
as in more debates as we go on uh
president trump vice president biden
it's been an interesting hour and a half
i want to thank you both
for participating in the first of three
debates that you have agreed to engage
in we want to thank case western reserve
university
and the cleveland clinic for hosting
this event the next debate sponsored by
the commission on presidential debates
will be one week from tomorrow october
7th at the university of utah
in salt lake city the two vice
presidential nominees vice president
mike pence and senator kamala harris
will debate at 9pm eastern that night we
hope you watch
until then thank you and good night
thank you
well welcome back to cleveland in ohio
where we have just watched that first
u.s presidential debate between donald
trump
and joe biden the two candidates
speaking for 90 minutes more than 90
minutes in fact taking questions on the
records of both men the supreme court
the covet 19 pandemic
the economy race and at the end there
the integrity
of the election it was bad tempered at
times
it was scratchy with more interruptions
than answers but the debate
will inform an important decision for
millions of americans watching at home
who do they want to lead their country
and we see as they
leave the stage there and those closest
to them also leave
the venue at the end of that debate